madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les membres du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés mes
chers
collègues ces derniers jours deux
tempêtes ont balayé la France
métropolitaine de la Bretagne à la Corse
occasionnant d'importants dégâts causant
la mort d'au moins trois personnes
d'autres pays sont touchés par ce
phénomène climatique exceptionnel qui
met durement à l'épreuve notre capacité
de résilience collective des milliers de
foyers ont été privés d'électricité 8
10000 connaissent encore des coupures
d'électricité de nombreux voyageurs ont
été bloqués plusieurs heures durant dans
des trains à l'arrêt le Pas de Calais
est toujours en alerte rouge et six
départements demeurent en vigilance
orange le nord les deux sèves la
Charente la Charente Maritime la
Dordogne et la Gironde dans ces
départements j'en appelle à la vigilance
de tous car des crux exceptionnels sont
en cours malgré les risques les élus les
collectivités territoriales les services
de secours nos forces for de l'ordre et
tous les autres services de l'État se
sont mobilisés et continuent de l'être
pour établir au plus vite des conditions
de vie normales et secourir les
personnes pas moins de 5000 agents de la
SNCF sont intervenus pour dégager plus
de 2000 arbres tombés sur les voies et
ont procédé à quelques 500 interventions
pour réparer les caténires je voudrais
que nous saluions ensemble le travail de
ces équipes qui ont pu rapidement
remettre les lignes en service ou mettre
en place des lignes de bus de
substitution
au nom
de au nom de la représentation nationale
je veux rendre hommage à l'ensemble des
pompiers secouristes policiers gendarmes
agents public bénévol qui n'ont pas
ménagé leurs efforts au service de leurs
concitoyens il mérite notre estime et
notre
reconnaissance parmi les victimes il y a
Frédéric Dépau agent de nedis il est
décédé en service électrocuté il était
venu du Gers pour secourir les abonnés
du
Finistère en sa mémoire et pour son
dévouement madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouverne mesdames et messieurs les
députés je vous demande de bien vouloir
observer une minute de
silence
je vous remercie